تعرضت القوات الامريكيه المنتشره في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط لنحو
158 هجوما عسكريا منذ بدء عمليه طوفان
الاقصى في السابع من اكتوبر الماضي ابرز
تلك الهجمات كانت في سوريا على قاعده
كونيكو والقاعده الامريكيه في حقل العمر
والشداد وقاعده ري ميلان والقاعده
الامريكيه في مطار خراب الجبر بمحافظه
الحسكه في العراق ايضا تعرض مطار اربيل
وقاعده عين الاسد لهجمات استهدفت قوات
امريكيه اخر هذه الهجمات كان يوم امس لكنه
في بلد ثالث حيث قتل ثلاثه ثلاثه عسكريين
امريكيين واصيب 34 اخرون في هجوم استهدف
قاعده عسكريه امريكيه في الاردن وهذه اول
مره يقتل فيها جنود امريكيون في المنطقه
منذ بدء الح الحرب الاسرائيليه على قطاع
غزه شبكه السي ان ان الامريكيه قالت ان
الهجوم تم بواسطه طائره مسيره كبيره الحجم
انطلقت بالتحديد من الاراضي السوريه
واستهدفت القاعده العسكريه الامريكيه
بالتحديد البرج
22 تقع هذه القاعده الامريكيه في شمال
شرقي الاردن وتحديدا بمحاذات الشريط
الحدودي مع سوريا تبعد 10 كيلومترات عن
الحدود مع العراق
كما تبعد نحو
22 كيلومترا عن قاعده التنف الامريكيه في
سوريا تضم القاعده 350 عسكريا امريكيا من
سلاحي البر والجو ينفذون عددا من مهام
الدعم الاساسيه وتقديم المشوره للقوات
الاردنيه حسب بيان القياده الوسطى
الامريكيه صحيفه واشنطن بوست نقلت عن
مسؤول عسكري في المقاومه الاسلاميه
بالعراق اعلانها مسؤول يتها عن الهجوم بل
وتاكيدها ان جميع المصالح الامريكيه في
المنطقه اهداف مشروعه لهجمات طالما استمرت
امريكا في دعم اسرائيل الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن وجه اصابع الاتهام مباشره الى ايران
دعونا
نستمع لقد مررنا بيوم صعب فليله الماضيه
فقدنا ثلاثه جنود شجعان في هجوم على احدى
قواعدنا في الشرق الاوسط اطلب دقيقه صمت
على ارواح هؤلاء الجنود الثلاثه الذين
سقطوا
وسنرد الخارجيه الايرانيه نفت صله طهران
بالهجوم واعتبرت الاتهامات الامريكيه
باطله وقالت في ب في بيان قوات والمقاومه
في المنطقه لا تتلقى الاوامر من ايران
وتتخذ قراراتها للدفاع عن الشعب الفلسطيني
باستقلاليه حذرنا مرارا من خطوره توسيع
دائره الصراع بسبب استمرار الهجمات
الاسرائيليه على غزه كيف علقتم انتم على
الهجوم على القاعده الامريكيه في الاردن
ومقتل الجنود دعونا نبدا هنا بحساب شاهين
يقول اذا كانت امريكا تتوقع انها امنه في
اي منطقه فهي واهمه خصوصا بعد مواقفها
ودعمها للكيان الصهيوني وانكار مجازر
ابناء غزه
وتنكر الاباده الجمعيه بكل بساطه ايضا نصل
الى عبد الماجد يقول اي استهداف ضد الكيان
الصهيون الامريكي بشكل مباشر او مصالحها
في البحر الاحمر او في اي مكان هو فعل
بطولي وهو اقل ما يمكن القيام به لمناصرته
التي تتعرض لحرب اباده من الكيان الصهيوني
وامريكا وصلنا الى جازم يقول مش بعيد انه
تكون اسرائيل وراء الحادث لتوريط امريكا
وغرسها معها بالوحل التي اصبحت غير قادره
على التعامل معه وتخليص نفسها واخيرا
وصلنا الى عبد الرحيم يقول ققول كل هذا من
اجل الكيان الصهيوني لانه بقاء الهيمنه
ببقاء هذا الكيان وامريكا تدافع عنه على
حساب مصالحها الاستراتيجيه وحياه جنودها
ولم تستطع ان تقول له كفى قتل واجرام منذ
اكثر من 100 يوم قاعده البرج 22 الامريكيه
لم تكن الوحيده التي اعلنت المقاومه
الاسلاميه في العراق استهدافها امس الاحد
فقد اعلنت استهداف اربع قواعد عسكريه
امريكيه ثلاث منها في سوريا وهي شداده
بمحافظه الحسكه الركبان والتنف في محافظه
حمص اما القاعده الرابعه فهي منشاه زفولون
البحريه شمال غربيه اسرائيل على البحر
[موسيقى]
المتوسط
y